this amazing little device holds a
thousand songs
and it goes right in my pocket
for more than two decades through
different shapes and sizes the ipod
brought us not only joy but a complete
change in culture
it may not have been the first mp3
player on the market but it was a gadget
that redefined how music is discovered
listened to and shared
[Music]
in the rich music city of liverpool it's
clear the ipod was a game changer for
many
everything was open to you didn't just
have to it wasn't what was in your
record shop
it wasn't just what was on at your local
cinema but it was whatever was out there
you could get access to and you could
have it everywhere you went and that's
to be honest from my generation that
that's still pretty mind-blowing
it's this product here which launched
apple towards becoming one of the most
valuable companies in the world but more
than that it's a design icon which
revolutionized the way we consume media
since its launch more than 400 million
ipods have been sold its release however
wasn't all positive
it signaled the decline of many high
street music stores
but its innovative appeal was just too
much
the first one i had is one of those kind
of click wheel ones one of the original
ones and i think it was just a case of
you could fit so much in your pocket
that was the uh the charm of it because
growing up you were used to you know a
cassette it was interesting at the time
being able to put your whole music
collection on this little thing that was
about that size we had an ipod mini
and uh yeah remember spending hours
ripping
towards a vinyl onto mp3 to put onto my
ipod apple's vision for the ipod evolved
rapidly with every generation they
introduce new technology which now
shapes how we're entertained and how we
communicate
when it first
came onto the scene it was focused
solely on sound but very quickly only
only three years after the original ipod
they
added uh video functionality to the ipod
and that sort of gave everyone a little
portable television that they carried
with them everywhere
as the ipod evolved into the iphone the
move to scrap production was inevitable
and as it's resigned to history in
museums and collections we're reminded
of its role in how we communicate
function and collaborate today
intimate rasheed sky news liverpool